SEATS THIS NOVEMBER, MIKE.
>> Mike: KRISTIN FISHER LIVE
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
KRISTIN, THANKS A LOT.
WELL, WE ARE DUSTING OFF OLD
QUOTES TONIGHT.
HERE'S ANOTHER.
MONEY IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF
POLITICS.
AND THAT LEADS US TO
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY'S
LOOK AT WHERE THE TWO
PARTIES STAND FINANCIALLY AS
WE HEAD INTO THE SUMMER
CAMPAIGN SEASON.
>> AS DEMOCRATS TRY TO MOUNT
A BLUE WAVE, SOME REPUBLICAN
STRATEGISTS ARE DEALING WITH
A RED ALERT.
THAT'S BECAUSE COMMITTEES
DEDICATED TO HELPING
DEMOCRATS FLIP CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE AND SENATE HAVE
NOW OUTRAISED REPUBLICAN
COMMITTEES DEDICATED TO
KEEPING CONTROL.
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE FEWER
DEMOCRATIC SENATE HOPEFULS,
THEIR CAMPAIGNS ARE RAKING
IN MORE THAN REPUBLICANS.
SAME STORY IN HOUSE RACES
WHERE THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE IS EMAILING
SUPPORTERS TO DONATE, QUOTE:
TO SHOW NANCY PELOSI WE
WON'T GO DOWN WITHOUT A
FIGHT.
BUT THE G.O.P. KNOWS IT'S A
LONG TIME UNTIL NOVEMBER.
>> MONEY IS LIKE HORSE SHOWS
AND HAND GRENADES YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE THE MOST JUST
BE CLOSE.
>> DCCC IS SPENDING
$3 MILLION AT LEAST IN
CALIFORNIA ADVANCE THE
PRIMARY TO GET A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT THROUGH TO THE
GENERAL.
>> A BRIGHT SPOT FOR THE
RIGHT, THE RNC HAS RAISED
ALMOST DOUBLE THE DNC'S
TOTAL.
THAT'S A DEFICIT THE DNC
DISMISSES.
>> THE RNC HAS ALWAYS
OUTRAISED OUR PARTY.
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT EXISTS,
IT'S ABOUT BEING CLEAR HOW
DO WE FIND MORE WAYS TO
MOBILIZE ITSELF.
THE REPUBLICANS OUTRAISE US
TWO TO 1 IN 2005 AND 2006
AND, YET, WE STILL TOOK BACK
THE HOUSE.
>> OUTSIDE MONEY IS POURING
INTO MID TERMS LEADERSHIP
FUND PLEDGING $48 MILLION
WORTH OF ADS IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION AND FROM THE LEFT
WITH LIBERAL BILLIONAIRE TOM
STIRS NEXT GGEN AMERICA
PUMPING IN $30 MILLION.
STIRS SPENT MONEY PLANNING
TO REMOVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM OFFICE.
>> A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
ONCE IMPEACHED A PRESIDENT
FROM FAR LEFT.
>> THEY HAVE DEVOLVED TO
BECOME MORE.
STYER IS BUYING JUST TO HAVE
ONE OF HIS SPOTS POP UP ON
TV AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
MAR-A-LAGO, OR WHEREVER ELSE
THE PRESIDENT MAY BE TUNED
IN.
>> THE THING THAT HE WANTS
THE MOST IN THE WHOLE WORLD
IS FOR DONALD TRUMP TO TWEET
AT HIM AND MAKE HIM, TOM
STIER, THE VOICE AND THE